je ne parle plus de la première mouture
ou des premières discussions nous avons
eu il ya deux ans maintenant sur comment
réformer le code du travail le rapport
combrexelle et d'autres rapports
badinter pour savoir comment nous
avançons il ya un texte qui a été
envoyée au conseil d'état ce texte eu
des interrogations de la part de gens de
gauche comme de droite la part du
patronat comme des syndicats de salariés
ce texte aujourd'hui il a été revu de
fond en comble c'est un vrai nouveau
départ qu'on a dit le premier ministre
ar ce curé crash mais c'est loin d'être
un crash parce que lorsque l'on fait le
compte personnel d'activité lorsque l'on
fait la garantie jeunes ces deux mesures
écoutez bien ce que je vais vous dire
sans des plus grandes mesures sociales
depuis 30 ans jamais nous n'aurons fait
cela jamais nous ne permettrons aux
jeunes d'avoir une garantie comme
celle-là ce qui pourrait s'apparenter
revenu universel le camp de personnel
d'activité la sécurité sociale
professionnelle demandé depuis des
lustres par tout le monde
nous la mettons en place la ces mesures
sont très forts et en même temps qui
aurait dit il ya six mois que nous
réformions le code du travail comme nous
l'avons fait jamais personne parce que
dans ce pays il ya ceux qui gesticulent
ni à ceux qui veulent que rien ne bouge
à l'heure où nous voulons bouger et en
même temps parce qu'il n'ya pas être
aveugle de sourds le gouvernement ne
présenterait plus qu'a entendu ce que
disaient les organisations syndicales ce
que disaient les jeunes ce que disaient
les français et nous sommes revenus sur
un syndrome de mesure oui alors ce que
nous avons à une ambition c'est de
réformer le pays avec les syndicats
réformistes et vous croyez que lier à
nouveau la contestation dans la rue du
côté des autres syndicats parlent que
des syndicats réformistes non mais il ya
aussi la cgt il ya il faut il ya l'unef
mais bien sûr vous avez des craintes
mais bien sûr mais c'est pas une crainte
c'est que
le mouvement va continuer puisque la cgt
fo et l'unef appellent à manifester les
étudiants demain ou après demain et puis
surtout le 31 mars
mais c'est pour ça que de lierre
jusqu'au 31 mars et jusqu'au conseil des
ministres il faut expliquer il faut
expliquer que cette loi est un hymne à
la jeunesse est faite pour elle parce
que nous voulons 0 précarité pour les
jeunes grâce à la garantie jeunes nous y
arriverons nous tous les jeunes 900
mille jeunes
neuf cent mille jeunes auront les moyens
de faire une formation ce n'était pas
assez le cas jusqu'à maintenant les
jeunes ont intérêt à cela
et puis par rapport aux salariés les
salariés ont tout intérêt à ce que les
entreprises puissent avoir un peu plus
de fluidité et d'efficacité
enfin quand on regarde ce qui se passe
dans les pme les tpe vous n'avez pas
convaincre parce que je vais interroger
sur les contestataires est ce que vous
créiez encore une explosion sociale bien
je vous réponds oui mais en même rayant
en expliquant donc je pense qu'un joueur
mais il ya un risque parce que des
mouvements de grève est une grève on
sait pas comment ils commencent on sait
pas comment ils finissent mais c'est par
l'explication par la conviction que nous
voulons essayer d'arriver à montrer à
ceux qui ceux qui se sentent représentés
nombreux derrière la cgt derrière et
faux derrière l'une est de se dire
regardez ce qui réellement la loi
bien trop souvent on parle du contexte
et pas du texte est en période de
grandes difficultés à perdre ou
l'exécutif aujourd'hui on le voit bien
est affaibli par un certain nombre de
critiques et du mans très européenne au
moment où le printemps arrivant la crise
des réfugiés va battre son plein nous va
poser plein de problèmes et bien avons
besoin d'unité de rassemblement
cette loi était mal parti oui elle est
bien là la brutalité
quelle brutalité elle est partie sur un
texte un prétexte un avant que mes
lloret conseil d'état il ya eu des
négociations pendant plus de six mois
pendant plus de six mois on ne le dit
pas tout ça parce que ça va vite parce
qu'on veut vraiment mettre dans le film
que on nous sommes raté la ministre l'a
dit oui mais nous aurions dû démarrer
différemment oui mais notre objectif
c'est le coq me est-ce que nommer
jacques a fait un pas en avant et c'est
comme cela qu'on répondra lors ils
constatent pas à cette occasion là un
changement quand même attitude presque
de personnalités de manuels
souvenez vous il ya très peu de temps il
nous disait j'irai jusqu'au bout elle ne
parle nous allons donner dialogue de
compromis des gouttes il s'échange et
qu'en même temps nous allons nous allons
aller jusqu'au bout nous allons faire
voter ce texte qui est essentielle mais
nous le faisons dans le dialogue
le premier ministre et le président de
la république se sont aperçus certains
disent trop tard mais peu importe
ils s'en sont aperçus qu'il manquait du
dialogue qu'il fallait recommencer une
deuxième mouture une chanson 15e les
deux parce qu'on qu'elle devrait avoir
l'impression que là la réforme telle
qu'elle apparaît aujourd'hui et plus le
fruit d'une synthèse hollandaise jeu
jours de décalage pour un texte c'est
pas énorme pour en arriver à ce qui
s'est passé hier à matignon où un
certain nombre d'organisations
syndicales ont dit que ça allait et où
le medef a dit que c'est pas si mal que
ça je pense que nous allons avancer dans
cette direction faire acte dans l'eau
c'est-à-dire n'y a pas d'euro 49,3 de la
non non mais là ça a été ça a été une
erreur de dire cela nous l'avons tous
reconnu en fait d'ailleurs 9,3 n'a pas
été prononcé mais nous prenons nos
responsabilités et et que ce n'est pas
bien on ne brutalise pas le vainqueur et
parlement le 49-3 existe mais je ne suis
pas favorable à cela ce texte
il doit passer sans le 49-3 pour le bien
des françaises et des français et de
l'économie française
pas trop de temps jean marie le guen
hausse a dit la révision elle est morte
et enterrée
je ne sais pas ce que fera la droite
sénatoriale ce que je pense ce que je
sais en tout cas c'est qu'il faut se
replacer le 16 novembre dernier
je crois que la droite s'est replacé le
10 novembre attendait d'eux le discours
du congrès de versailles
la situation post attentat est le fait
que le présent la république ait su
rassembler la nation et faire des
propositions
il a fait des propositions congrès un
premier texte a été sorti fin fin
décembre et on s'est aperçu l'encore
parce que nous avons des divergences
avec la droite sur la façon de nous
comporter que la version présentée par
le président de la république qu'on veut
de versailles n'obtenait pas les 3 5e du
parlement
il a donc fallu le président qui parle
de déchéance de nationalité qui parle
des binationaux et alors et alors
aujourd'hui on arrive à quoi comme qu'on
premier à l'assemblée nationale eh bien
justement je vais vous expliquer très
tranquillement je sois que aujourd'hui
vous chercher toutes les bisbilles tout
les petits élèves il m'a dit eh quoi et
ne pas parler du fond c'est peut-être
votre sélectionneur je pense qu'aux
téléspectateurs s'intéresse au fond oui
mais je vais vous répondre
la proposition du président de la
république de l'assemblée du du congrès
de versailles
après l'avoir mis sur la table nous nous
sommes aperçus il s'est aperçu qu'il n'y
avait pas de possibilité d'avoir une
majorité des trois cinquièmes ni à
gauche ni à droite parce que je rappelle
que pour qu'un congrès ait lieu il faut
que la droite et la gauche
dans le cadre de l'unité nationale voulu
par nos concitoyens s'entendent il ya
donc eu vivre le nom plutôt à gauche
qu'à droite
à droite aussi vous étiez victime de vos
divisions du parti socialise au parti
socialiste tout le monde n'était pas
favorable au texte à l'atterrissage de
l'assemblée nationale mais je rappelle
quand même que à droite et non des
moines messieurs jupé messieurs fillon
qui ont beaucoup d'amis sénateurs et
sénatrices ici même dans cette maison
n'est pas favorable
donc il a fallu trouver une piste
d'atterrissage la piste d'atterrissage
c'était de dire ce qui est mal vécu par
beaucoup de nos concitoyens par beaucoup
de parlementaires c'est de stigmatiser
les binationaux mois at-il personnel je
ne pensais pas aux binationaux je
pensais aux terroristes et c'est la
réflexion que j'ai sur la nation on peut
acquérir la nation française et j'en
suis très fier
on peut aussi en être déchu si on veut
la détruire et si on veut faire un acte
de terrorisme
il se trouve si vous permettez il se
trouve que il n'y avait pas de
possibilité de 3/5 sur ce texte parce
qu'il avait la stigmatisation à
l'assemblée nationale le texte qui a été
voté à plus des trois cinquièmes par les
socialistes et par le groupe l'est
républicain
c'est de ne plus stigmatiser à mais au
risque de créer des apatrides nord
laissez moi finir c'est de ne plus
stigmatiser les binationaux n'ont pas du
tout depuis ni stigmatisé d'humiliation
nos essais de faire une déchéance plus
globale et il faudra rennais la patrie
attendait ce option si on ratifie la non
aujourd'hui il a le droit d'être de
s'exprimer ne pas être tenus pour
quantité négligeable mais ici il s'agit
pas de quantité négligeable
il s'agit de positions politiques pour
arriver éventuellement ou non à un vote
au congrès et l'amendement qui
présentait par la majorité sénatoriale
pour revenir à la déchéance pour les
binationaux pour nous n'est plus
acceptable
elle n'est plus acceptable puisque
l'assemblée a fait un pas en avant mais
c'est pas de l'assemblée nationale face
au sénat puisque dans une révision
constitutionnelle l'assemblée nationale
mais aborder cela vous pas trop des
sénateurs vous n'êtes pas d'accord non
je ne suis pas d'accord
chaque d'accord également avec une ligne
idée de navettes de nouveaux compromis
entre les deux chambres
je ne suis pas d'accord parce qu'il faut
bien se rendre sur ce qu'il faut bien se
rendre compte c'est qu'on est dans un
projet de loi constitutionnelle pas un
projet de loi ordinaire et un projet de
loi constitutionnelle
il n'y a pas de commission mixte
paritaire la navette peut durer six mois
donc quand le président du sénat dit les
discussions avec l'assemblée doivent se
faire après le vote en première lecture
au sénat russe étrange je me permettrais
pas de dire ça mais je conteste cet
argument parce que les discussions elles
ont démarré depuis le 16 novembre et que
aujourd'hui les sénateurs de la majorité
sénatoriale aurait pu essayer de se
rapprocher de l'assemblée peut-être
différemment mais à partir du moment où
la posture des républicains et du
président du sénat c'est de dire on ne
veut pas revenir là dessus
alors il sera difficile qu'il y ait une
qu'il y ait une victoire les 3 5es
bénéfices' y aura pas de résistance
génération vous écoute pas du tout je
vous dis que si le sénat ne bougeait pas
de l'écriture ce qui va être présenté
demain alors il ne pourra pas y avoir
trois cinquièmes en gagnant ce que je
cherche moi c'est de la cohérence et la
cohérence nous voulons qu'elles se
fassent à partir de la majorité
sénatoriale
si elle nous et demain qui peuvent
bouger de ce qu'ils vont voter ou pas si
la majorité sénatoriale nous disait
demain
voilà notre position lors demandé de
bouger c'est apprendre et elle c'est à
prendre ou à laisser
alors qu'à l'assemblée nationale il ya
eu des efforts des deux côtés de la part
des républicains et des socialistes pour
arriver à un premier compromis s'il ne
bouge pas on arrêtera là et moi je ne
sais si je vais vous répondre mais moi
il me semble que dans un cas comme celui
ci
si vraiment il ne bougeait pas je ne
serai pas favorable à ce qu'il y ait
encore des navettes eu un temps comme un
travail vraiment ma position elle est
simple elle est simple une navette
maximum à condition qu'on sache qu'ils
puissent qu'il ya une volonté d'avancer
parce que je vous dis franchement
martineau dollar est là quand je suis
retourné dans le département de la drôme
ces trois derniers jours leur faim
vendredi samedi et dimanche
personne ne me parle de la déchéance de
nationalité c'est très longue c'est
depuis novembre donc il faut que ça se
termine ce sujet est suffisamment
important sur l'occasion de m'exprimer
demain à la tribune du sénat au nom du
au nom du groupe
je porterai la parole du groupe y
compris les dix les différences mais là
maintenant ça ne peut pas durer encore
six mois
depuis plus de six mois stéphane le foll
ici même au sénat au cours d'une table
ronde s'est battu pour imposer un prix
un prix minimum d'achat pour le pour le
port et pour le pour la viande bovine
il se trouve que les apporteurs les
industriels l'ont refusé on ne peut pas
leur imposer qu'on est là il a fallu
faire pression et il a fait pression
puis la crise est accentuée évidemment
il ya beaucoup de tracteurs dans la rue
beaucoup de détresse
moi qui suis fils d'agriculteur je peux
pas me être être content de voir de voir
des agriculteurs qui sont presqu'à la
rue qui peuvent tout perdre et compris
leur maison enfin il y apparaît cision
il n'y a pas une seule profession en
france
qui accepterait de vendre ses produits
inférieur au prix de revient
cette table à quiconque tue d'autres
plateaux le cas en public sénat l'a
acheté elle l'a achetée à quelqu'un qui
est fixé un prix quand vous voulez
manger acheter du lait où vous les
mangez de la viande de porc de la viande
de boeuf on vous dit pas combien vous la
vendre du voilà combien je voulais
acheter
ce n'est pas possible donc le ministre a
fait monter très fortement l'attention
au niveau européen mais l'europe est
dirigée par la droite et libéral je
m'excuse de dire ça donc vous voyez le
gan communaux dont je parle des pays et
donc il fallait trouver une majorité de
pays la france ne l'a pas trouvée parce
que phil hogan le commissaire européen
qui est ultra libérale producteurs de
lait irlandais a fait partie de ceux qui
étaient contre les quotas laitiers
nous étions opposés à la fin des quotas
laitiers la droite française était pour
et aujourd'hui on voit ce qui se passe
donc ce qui a été demandé c'est
d'arrêter
à certains endroits la surproduction
c'est pas des quotas qui sont remis
c'est à dire oui mais tant mieux moi
j'aimerais que les quotas reviennent je
vous dis franchement j'aimerais qu'on
remette les quotas laitiers
parce que l'art est d'aller jusque-là
non mais la fin des quotas laitiers
c'est la fin de beaucoup d'éleveurs dans
notre heure dans notre pays donc il y
aura ça il faut aller âge il faut alors
l'éthique le talent c'est indispensable
le commissaire avait toujours refusé
jusque là quand le ministre lui demander
il a accepté pour trois ans c'est une
belle et les cliques d'acheter quoi ces
viandes de france produits transformés
qui seront mis surtout les sur tous les
emballages qui monteront au français moi
j'en appelle au patriotisme
nos concitoyens je suis sûr que les
françaises et les français qui font
leurs courses préférées
si tel qu'il cap et un centime de
centimes 300 types 10 centimes de plus
pour acheter de la viande française
plutôt que de l'acheter de l'hiver à
l'éthique dans sa série musulmans chose
oui
la troisième chose c'est l'embargo russe
qui ne réglera pas tout mais il faut que
l'europe c'est pas la france qui est
d'essayer de l'embargo sur la russie
c'est l'europe
alors prête à bouger et donc quand mieux
notamment sur l'embargo sanitaires
un manuel valls dit après d'autres dans
cette interview que françois hollande
est le candidat naturel légitime
est ce que à force de le répéter ben
finalement ça montre pas plutôt que
c'est pas si évident non je crois que
c'est le candidat légitime mais que pour
les français aujourd'hui ce n'est pas
évident il faut appeler un chat un chat
aujourd'hui encore on regarde la cote de
popularité du président la république
elle est faible elle est faible parce
que nous en parlions tout à l'heure la
france est déchiré structures et des
structures et parce que les mesures qui
sont prises vont dans le bon sens mais
ne pas passer leurs fruits de chômage et
l'économie et c'est parce que nous
voyons bien que la ligne de sens
politique que nous voulons donner n'est
pas assez compris parce que nous ne
sommes pas assez bons pour pour
l'expliquer donc il ne s'agit pas de
dire à moore niveau personnel pour
l'exploit je vais beaucoup d'efforts
mais j'ai ben oui mais je suis là pour
ça parce que si on ne fait pas d'efforts
ça ne marchera pas et d'ailleurs pour
moi c'est pas un effort c'est un plaisir
donc je pense vraiment que françois
hollande on va pas dire naturel parce
que ça porte chance cette personne du
candidat naturel
mais le candidat légitime il est
président sortant nous sommes dans la
vème république
nous ne sommes pas en espagne en italie
en allemagne ou c'est là c'est la
proportionnelle qui n'emporte nous
sommes au scrutin majoritaire
donc si françois hollande décide de se
représenter à l'élection présidentielle
de 2017
ce que je souhaite et ce que j'espère
alors il sera le credo suicidaire ni la
légitime et évidemment il n'y aura pas
de primaires à gauche
le président de la république se
présentant il va pas faire une primaire
et je pense qu'il peut y arriver mais
moi je vois prend régulièrement françois
hollande en réunion ou en privé je n'ai
jamais entendu parlé une seule fois
d'élection présidentielle 2017 jamais y
compris sur la primaire nous avons une
opposition
j'ai même lu parfois que il est il est à
l'elysée que à l'elysée je sais pas qui
c'est que françois hollande pourrait
participer à la primaire il ne nous a
jamais parlé
aujourd'hui nous parlons terrorisme nous
parlons code du travail
nous parlons sociale nous parlons
jeunesse nous parlons éducation nous
parlons formation et il est à sa tâche
jusqu'au bout le reste ne nous intéresse
pas et puis à la fin de l'année il
prendra sa position à l'automne à la fin
de l'année et puis en fonction de cette
position s'il est candidat je ferai
partie de ce
parce que nous serons nombreux qu'ils
soutiendront primaire ou pas primaire et
moi je vous ai dit que je n'étais pas
favorable parce qu'il va pas aller
battre le pavé
c'est pas pour débattre avec les copains
enfin il a autre chose à faire que
d'aller battre les estrades et que
prépare et que tu rates faire son
travail de chef de l'état et puis s'il
n'y va pas mais là il y aura une
primaire où je sais pas dans quel cas le
froid mais nous choisirons qui ne pensez
vous de l'option makiso il se prépare on
a l'impression en faire un tous les cas
la presse l'a senti comme cela là je
vais vous répondre très sincèrement je
n'en sais rien je ne sais pas qui sera
candidat dans ce cas là enfin ce que je
pense c'est que si françois hollande
n'allez pas à l'élection présidentielle
de 2007 pour une vente pour une autre
qu'il choisisse ou qu'il ne puisse pas y
aller ou je ne sais trop
on serait dans une telle situation
politique que après il faudrait essayer
quand même me semble-t-il de nous serrer
les coudes et de sauver les meubles et
une candidature d'arnaud montebourg qui
a également évoqué régulièrement et
qu'il a pour le coup pourrait être face
à françois hollande il a arrêté la
politique qui les dents il est dans le
privé peut-être viendra-t-il je ne sais
pas s'il a envie de se croyaient pas ces
rumeurs de retour
non mais moi j'ai une croix à aucune
aucune rumeur il ya solutré à beuvry jeu
mais pas les deux sur le même plan parce
que c'est lui qui est monté sur du très
pendant des années il a été président de
la république
il avait une carrure françois mitterrand
absolument énorme mais le sujet n'est
pas là on verra montebourg amant
d'autres peut-être martine aubry marie
noëlle lienemann notre collection
adressé annoncé qu'elle était à toulouse
puis avoir vingt candidats à l'élection
présidentielle
le sujet n'est pas là c'est comme ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui à droite enfin le
spectacle qui sera donné par la droite
et par la gauche
six à douze candidats de droite et une
dizaine de carrières de gauche mais vous
savez je vais vous dire une chose ce
n'est c'est un sentiment personnel pas
du tout une attaque vis-à-vis de qui que
ce soit mais je ne crois pas un instant
qu'il y ait une douzaine de membres des
républicains capable d'être président de
la république comme une douzaine de
socialistes capables de prison à un
public capable d'être candidat à la
candidature à une primaire oui mais être
président de la république dans l'état
où en est avec une europe en grande une
envoyé quand elle mange non mais moi je
dis plus rien à voir il peut y avoir
deux ou trois des républicains qui ont
la carrure et je pense que aujourd'hui à
gauche parce qu'il est président de la
république c'est françois hollande qui
est le mieux à même de faire de faire
cela et s'il essaie de ne pas l'être
nous avons la chance d'avoir des talents
et nous choisirons parmi deux ou trois
talons
une